-Alright, sweetheart.
I'm gonna go inside.
I'm gonna get your koala, okay?
But I need you
to stay in the car.
Got it?
-I got it.
-[ Taps car ]
-Sir, you have to leave
the premises immediately.
You're not welcome here.
-Uh-oh.
-Brother man, I'm going into
that house to get something.
Either I go through you,
or you go through me.
-You shouldn't have...
[ Both grunting ]
-Ew.
-It's okay, baby.
We actually went
to high school together.
We're just catching up.
-Daddy, watch out!
[ Both grunting ]
-Aah! Oh!
Too young for this [Bleep].
-Welcome back to "Late Night.
Wwe're here with Ike Barinholtz,
everybody.
-I'm tellin' you, that was good.
-This is a wonderful premise
for a television show.
-Yes.
-It's a whodunnit.
-Almost like an Agatha
Christie-style whodunnit,
where, over the course
of each episode,
we see a different genre...
-Yes.
-...based on the perspective of
who's telling us the story.
You're the second episode,
your character,
and it's lovely to watch because
it's sort of an action episode.
-Yeah, my guy is --
Each genre is appropriate
for that character,
and my guy is kind of
a sad, middle-aged man.
So action movie felt natural.
-Yep.
-I was very inspired by
Vin Diesel,
but also Steven Seagal,
because I, too, have trouble
raising my leg for a kick.
-Yeah.
I've known you long enough to
know that was not your leg.
-You don't know that.
That could have been.
Depends on the angle.
-If you did a headstand,
your leg wouldn't be that high.
[ Laughter ]
-He's joking, folks.
I'm very flexible in life.
-I want to get back to the show.
Since we're talking about
flexibility and what-not, you
have an issue to take with me.
-Yeah, I do.
-Because we're
on a friendly text chain.
-It was friendly.
It was friendly at one point.
-I did not realize
that I had run afoul
of your feelings like this.
-Yeah, so, we're on
a text chain together.
And a couple weeks ago,
Seth said, "Hey,
I saw 'West Side Story,'
and you dance like --"
and he named one of the
performers in "West Side Story."
And I was like, "Oh, thanks."
He says, "Yeah,
it's not a compliment."
And that hurt my feelings
so much.
Only because, Seth, like, we've
danced together many times.
-Yeah, yeah, we have.
-And you know the vibe I bring.
You know the [Bleep ] I bring
on the dance floor.
-Yeah.
-It's hot.
People are in a good mood
when I dance.
-We always say it's like
drinks at Tommy Bahamas.
-Yeah, it is.
[ Laughter ]
And so, when you said that,
I felt the need to kind of
have some people vouch
for my dancing abilities.
So I've actually
brought some clips.
Do you mind if I --
-Are these celebrity clips?
-Some of them are.
-Okay.
-Alright, so, let's see
what we got up there, folks.
Let's see, who do we have first
who can vouch
and say that I'm a good dancer?
What do we got?
-Hi, Seth.
-I just wanted to tell you that
Ike was a very good dancer.
He brings joy to people
when he dances.
-Ike, we're very proud of you.
Bye-vye.
-Okay.
-That's my parents.
-That's great.
-And I thought
they did a great job.
-And for your dad
to take time off
from his job
in the Irish Mafia...
[ Laughter ]
-The film "Belfast"
was based off of
my father's real experience.
-Okay, first of all,
so, that's just your parents.
-Are you saying they're liars?
-I'm just saying they maybe
have a different standard
for what counts as good dancing.
-So, if there was someone
who I wasn't related to,
would that maybe --
-It would matter more.
-Let's roll clip number 2, guys.
Let's see what we got.
-Hey, Seth. It's Mindy.
Ike wanted me to reach out
to you to tell you
that he's a really good...
-Dancer.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, so, right at the end...
-Right at the end.
-...your voice.
-No, sir.
Mindy had a cold.
She had a head cold.
She said
she didn't want to do it.
She said, "My voice is weird."
I said, "Just do it, Mind,
please."
So, I mean, that's
pretty much case closed.
-I think, case def still open.
-Okay.
Okay, if there was someone
you really loved and trusted
and really looked up to,
even from an early age.
-Okay.
-Let's roll that third clip,
please.
Thank you.
-Hey, Seth, it's baseball
Hall of Famer Wade Boggs here.
I heard you were talking smack
about Ike and his dancing.
Just want to say,
that's not cool, man.
Ike is a great dancer,
and when he starts moving,
he gets everyone excited.
And you're no Fred Astaire,
believe me.
-Boom.
-Wade Boggs out.
-Okay, so, your childhood idol
just basically said
you were acting like a [bleep].
-Yeah.
Now, I do -- I mean, I loved
Wade Boggs, growing up.
I don't, like, trust him.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
A Hall of Fame baseball player!
That cost me $300, man!
[ Laughter ]
-You have the wrong cameo
if that cost $300!
-It was either him
or Franco Harris.
I don't have that kind of money.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, before we go --
and, again, congratulations
on the show.
It's wonderful.
It's a great cast.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, and we're gonna
have dinner later,
and I don't want you to be like,
"Hey, man, where was my plug?"
-Yah, no, I gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
-You, uh -- You know --
and, again, we've talked about
comedy since the day we met --
we're both huge fans
of David Letterman,
and he's gonna be here
tomorrow night.
-I know, it's crazy.
And I asked --
David Letterman is gonna be here
tomorrow night.
-There we go.
Finally popped one.
-That's the big one.
-Finally popped one.
And I asked if I could
be on the show again.
Shoemaker shut that down.
-Yeah.
-Um, so, I was wondering --
I have a little gift,
if you could give it to Dave.
-A gift?
Because again, it's the 40th
anniversary of his show.
-Yeah, and I want him
to feel like it's not --
you're not the only fan
of his here.
So I have a nice headshot
right there.
if we can get a nice tight shot
of that.
It says, "To Dave,
thanks for all the laughs.
Best, Ike Barinholtz."
-That's great.
-If you could give that
to Dave tomorrow --
-That's beautiful,
because that definitely
just came right off a printer.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I carry these
in my carry-on.
You ever see him on a flight,
folks, feel free to ask for one.
[ Laughter ]
Free of charge.
Mention promo code
"Late Night With Seth Meyers.
-You guys, that's
Ike Barinholtz.
New episodes of "The Afterparty"
are available Fridays
on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with Bridget Everett.
-Right here on the couch.
Right here.